[Music]
Hello, how are you? Sali Jaramillo greets you
with your informative brief for today, Tuesday
, August 10. If you receive unemployment benefits,
we remind you that these
expire soon, the last day will be
September 4, this includes the
$300 weekly
unemployment compensation assistance  for those who
lost their jobs and
extended benefits from the state for more
details visit our page and snap
dotcom the section in spanish changing the
subject for all this week las vigas
bolívar and only one lane will be open
in both directions between elvis presley
return and  exaggerate avenue
clark county commissioners recommend using
alternate routes as drivers could
witness delays in this area this is
part of a project that includes seven
passes to improve las vegas boulevard
they are also renovating pipelines
crosswalks and lighting
you haven't gotten your cob shot yet  and
we tell you about the clinics available
during this s  week there will be two today and
tomorrow from four to six in the afternoon
at peter and penny lane schools tomorrow
there will be one inside the golden nugget hotel and casino
from 9 to 11 in the morning another two
will be organizing Thursday and Friday
at face and high schools  scorpion
these will be from 4 to 6 pm
all schools also offer the
required immunizations for children
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a hot day reaching
105 degrees for today there is a slight
chance of rain for around the
valley tomorrow stay at  the same
temperature, however, will rise to
107 degrees as we approach the
beautiful weekend on the 6th.